Hello, everyone.
I would like to welcome you to today's
webinar entitled Using Genomics,
Wearables and
Big Data to Manage Health and Disease.
My name is Annette Cruz and I'm the
Program Manager of the Stanford Genetics
and Genomics Certificate Program
at the Stanford Center for
Professional Development.
This webinar is brought to you
by the Stanford Center for
Professional Development and the Stanford
Genetics and Genomics Certificate Program.
Take online courses in genetics and
genomics and
gain a greater understanding of biology,
human health and personalized medicine.
Happened through the world class
research of Stanford faculty and
industry experts to acquire the skills and
knowledge you need to succeed in
the rapidly evolving genetics industry.
Visit geneticscertificate.stanford.edu
to learn more.
Before we begin, I would like to introduce
you to today's featured presenter,
Dr. Michael Snyder.
Dr. Snyder is a Stanford Ascherman
Professor and Chair of Genetics and
the Director of the Center of Genomics and
Personalized Medicine.
Dr. Snyder received Ph.D training at
the California Institute of Technology and
carried out postdoctoral
training at Stanford University.
He is the leader in the field
of functional genomics and
proteomics and one of the major
participants of the ENCODE project.
His laboratory study was the first
to perform a large scale functional
genomics project in any organism.
And has launched many technologies
in genomics and proteomics that have
been used for characterizing genomes,
proteomes and regulatory networks.
I would like to turn it over to Mike now.
>> Great, well, thanks very much for
having me on this program.
I look forward to telling you about some
of the things we're up to using data to
help manage people's health.
And ideally help manage their,
ideally cure their disease.
So this is an area, I think many of you
appreciate, is incredibly hot these days
and very topical and I think one of the
events that really launched this was when
Obama announced that we're going to have
a major initiative in precision medicine.
This was in his inaugural
address in January 2015,
and he pointed to this DNA helix as
the way in which we're going to be able
to use genomics and information to be
able to better manage people's health.
Well, I would argue this goes
well beyond just genomics.
I think we're going to see
an explosion of all kinds of
data that will help manage
people's health and
predict medicines they should use at
a level that's never been done before.
Now, before we dive into this,
let me first show you a little bit
about what frames our thinking.
Which is that your health,
if you will, it's a state.
And most of the time,
we're healthy and in a healthy state.
But there are times in which we get
disease and we become unhealthy.
When you get a viral infection or
perhaps even other nastier diseases.
And these states, they are influenced
by many different things.
They are influenced by your DNA, your so
called genome which is a collection
of all your DNA molecules.
And also, the various things you're
exposed to, the so called expose zones.
That would be the foods you eat,
pathogens you might be exposed to,
various life stresses, exercise.
We all know intuitively that these
will contribute to your health.
And I would argue that a goal of us
collectively, is to try and understand,
in quantitative terms,
exactly how people, when they're born
with a certain DNA sequence, when they
are exposed to different molecules.
What kind of health
outcome we might predict?
And I think this will occur in some,
if you will, probabilistic fashion.
Some means in which we
would be able to predict
whether someone might be healthy or
get disease.
In just as an example,
if you're at risk for Parkinson's,
you probably don't want
to be a pesticide worker.
Because that makes you at higher risk for
getting Parkinson's.
So, and there are DNA variants
that lead to Parkinson's.
So again I think this is where
we're only we going to head.
I do believe we're in a world where
soon people will be getting their genome
sequence before they're born.
And that will actually make that all the
more important we understand what kinds
of exposures lead to what
kind of health outcomes.
Now I think many of you know it's
possible to sequence people's DNA.
So there's been a revolution of DNA
sequencing technology when it's at
the point where we can now sequence
someone's DNA for less than $2000.
Although to interpret that DNA
sequence costs a lot more.
In fact, it can cost as much as 15 or
$20,000.
But that's not the only revolution
in technology that's occurring.
There's other revolutions and
advanced technologies, mass spectrometry,
the sorts of instruments
that you see in airports,
there is very advanced instruments that
let us measure tens of thousands of
molecules inside of us that again at
a level that has never been done before.
So we can make measurements
of unprecedented scale and
be able to better define what
people's biochemical states are.
So a number of years ago,
we launched a large project which
we call Personal Omics Profiling,
where the idea is to make very
detailed measurements of people.
So we make literally billions of
measurements of people every time we
sample them.
So we analyze their DNA, that's
their genome, as I mentioned before.
But we also analyze all these
other features as well.
So something called the epigenome,
which is your modified DNA.
Which we know is influenced by the
environment and all those other things I,
mentioned earlier.
We also measure all your RNA molecules.
This is called your transcriptome.
All your proteins, that's your proteome.
Special set of proteins called cytokines.
They modulate your immune system.
Then we follow all your metabolites and
small molecules, as well.
Or as many as we can measure.
We follow your antibody responses.
You may have heard about this
new area called microbiome.
This is an area where we actually have
many, many cells that live in and
on us that are really microbes that are
actually very beneficial for our health.
They digest our food and
we study that as well.
So we actually measure,
most of these we measure out of blood but
some we measure out of urine and
the microbiome, we actually measure,
believe it or not,
out of your stool sample.
Between each measurements of all
these different things, again,
billions of measurements
every time we sample people.
And the idea is actually to sample people
over time to see what keeps them healthy
and what makes them,
what goes wrong when they get sick.
And we do standard medical tests over here
as well, we also have questionnaires.
And I'm going to get back to these
wearable sensors at the end of
the talk today.
So basically, why are we doing all this?
Well we're trying to understand why people
are healthy, what keeps them healthy.
And by understanding
the biochemical measures of health.
We also wonder what happens when they
do get sick and when you do a get
diseases what kinds of biochemical
events change during that time.
And then how can we better manage that.
We want to understand how these different,
I mentioned omes, so
the proteome is your collection
of proteins and the metabolome
is your collection of metabolites and your
microbiome is your collection of microbes.
We want to understand how
they relate to one another.
We know intuitively that the food you
eat in combination with your genome and
your biochemical marks on your
DNA somehow affect your health.
But we don't really understand
how those rules work and
we'd like to understand how they work so
that we'll be able to Better manage your
health, that is to say, that certain foods
can make you better by eating them, and
they will be specific for
some individuals.
We like people to eat those foods and
not foods that make you unhealthy,
and this can be very personalized.
We're also trying to understand
how people react similarly and
how they react differently when you're
faced with, say, adverse conditions.
If you have a virus that comes along,
most people respond somewhat similarly,
in the sense that they'll
mount an immune response.
But there will be personal
aspects to this, as well.
Some people will make certain cytokines,
and
be able to better fend off that virus and
others, not so good.
And we'd like to understand
why that's the case.
And perhaps, most importantly,
one major reason we're doing this
project is we're trying to
identify factors that can,
basically, help manage
the health of an individual.
We can learn things about people that
we hope will keep them healthy, and
you'll see evidence of
that as we go along.
So, basically, many of you may
have known this already, but
we actually started this
project by studying me.
Looks like we lost some information here.
But, basically, we've been profiling
me for, now, over six and a half years,
meaning we've taken over 200 time points
from me, many samples at each time point.
And during this time,
I've been through ten viral infections,
I've also had lyme disease.
And we basically have,
as I say, been analyzing me and
following me very closely
over this period.
And we did this because we wanted to see,
again,
what happens when I'm healthy and
what goes wrong when I get sick.
So every one of these boxes
is a viral infection.
It's supposed to be a timeline,
here, that somehow got lost.
But, basically, during every one of these
viral infections, I have gotten sick.
And we've take many, many samples.
So, for example,
these are all common colds I've had.
This is a rhinovirus, HRV.
This is a respiratory syncytial virus,
that's the common cold in kids.
Adenovirus is another one.
And so we do a dense sampling
when I get a viral infection.
And then we typically give blood every
two to three months when I'm healthy.
And lately I've been trying different
dietary supplements that we've been
sampling a lot.
Each of these is a day number,
each of these numbers.
And so, again,
we're following what happens as I
go through these various changes.
And the first thing we did
was actually sequence my DNA.
I'll go through this somewhat quickly
because I'd like to talk about some new,
exciting stuff.
But from my DNA sequence, we could predict
my risk for many different diseases.
And most of this I knew
from my family history or
I know about myself already,
meaning I was at low risk for obesity.
Nobody in my family has
ever been overweight.
I was at high risk for what's called
dyslipidemia and high cholesterol,
that shows up here as high triglycerides.
I was at high risk for those.
I knew that already because I
knew my cholesterol was high, and
I do take statins to manage that.
High risk for coronary artery disease,
that was done as well.
One of the big surprises from my genome,
though, was I was at high risk for
type 2 diabetes.
Basically, I went from having
a 27% chance of having
this in my lifetime to a 46% chance,
so a huge increase.
And we actually were following my glucose,
which is what happens when you get
diabetes, your glucose goes off.
And, in fact, that did happen to
me during the course of the study.
My glucose had been
marching along just fine.
Then it actually turns out right
after this nasty respiratory
syncytial virus infection,
my glucose went quite off.
It got very high to the point where I was,
in fact, classified as diabetic.
So when we first measured,
it was on its way up at 127,
a week later it was even higher.
This is a better measure for steady state
glucose, it's called hemoglobin A1C.
It was right on the edge, it's arbitrary.
But diabetes is classified as 6.5,
hemoglobin A1C at a 6.4
is right on the edge.
And then five weeks later,
we measure me again and, sure enough,
I was actually diabetic.
I had crossed the threshold, I was 6.7.
And that was over five years ago,
that was April 11,
2011 because up until then I
had the world's worst diet.
I ate cake, sweets,
I didn't know I had a problem.
I cut all that out,
I doubled my biking and started running.
And it took about eight months, but
I brought it down under control.
I got my glucose back together.
So this made a big splash
at the time because it's
the first time someone used their genome
to predict their risk for a disease.
In my case, I got the disease.
And in my case it was also manageable, and
I was able to bring it under control,
at least initially.
And it was also quite intriguing
because if notice when it occurred,
it occurred right after this nasty
respiratory syncytial virus infection.
So what we think is that I'm genetically
predisposed for type 2 diabetes, and
then in conjunction with this
nasty viral infection, or
its associated stress response,
that's what's triggered the disease.
Now, you may think that this all has a
happy ending, and it's not completely so.
It turns out that some people,
in fact, criticize and say maybe,
Mike, that would have gone away
on its own, you don't know that.
But we accidentally did the right
control experiment, so to speak.
That is to say, we kept profiling me,
but we were doing so blindly.
It was actually when we scaled,
you'll see in a minute,
that we now follow 100
people just like me.
And when we scaled,
we had stopped looking at the data, so
we were doing this blindly.
And then at this point here somebody
looked at my hemoglobin A1C,
which turned out to be 7.0, and said,
Mike, you're 7.0, you're diabetic again.
I said, I had no idea, so they sampled me.
I'd stopped running, so I started running,
and I could bring it a little
bit under control to 5.7.
But these days it's actually drifted up,
in fact,
when I got Lyme disease it hit 6.5.
And it's gone up high again recently.
So these things,
it hovers between 6.2 and 6.4.
There's no question I have
a metabolic disorder, and
it's not fully under control because I'm
right on the verge of being diabetic.
So, again, this is hemoglobin A1C,
this is glucose, and
I'm way elevated over what I should be.
And it's just not me, my brothers and
sisters all have elevated glucose.
We're all fairly thin, so
it's a little bit surprising.
But it's pretty clear, then,
that we have a genetic predisposition for
type 2 diabetes.
And that's what the first
one is with type 2.
So basically, again,
this is a case where genomics and
genetics actually predicted disease risk.
In my case,
I could always partially manage it.
I'll probably be doing other
things like taking drugs to get my
glucose under control in the future.
Now, since that time,
we've actually carried out
other kinds of assays, as well.
We did an IMAX movie-type
picture of my biochemistry
as it changes during the time I get
sick to when we got type 2 diabetes.
But we've actually been making
other measurements, as well.
One very fascinating area is the field
of epigenetics and epigenomics.
Epigenomics is a collection of your
modifications to your chromosomes,
if you will.
And one important set of
modifications is there's chemical
modifications called DNA methylation.
So what's interesting is that
we know that your DNA can get
modified in response to
various environmental cues.
But we don't fully understand it,
a very fascinating field.
But we know that this one in particular,
modification of your DNA by
genome methylation,
which is a chemical modification,
we know it's affected by nutrition and
affected by things like exercise,
even your age and other environmental cues
all affect your epigenetic programming.
We also know that it's associated with
modification with turning off your genes,
so we don't how the whole thing works,
but we do know it's very, very important,
and so, the things you do will directly
affect your gene and your health.
And there are now ways of mapping out
all your modified DNA sites, something
called whole genome bisulfate sequencing,
deferrals, in this case, I know.
But you can actually map out all
of the modifications in your DNA,
and there a millions of
them using this technology.
So, we've done this for me,
and it's quite fascinating,
you can see very interesting reads
into the genome that change.
One area that we think is
interesting is trying to use your
DNA modification to predict what
diseases you might be at risk for,
just like we used your genome sequencing
to predict what diseases you might catch.
We can also look at your modified
DNA to try and do that, as well,
to understand what diseases
you might be at risk for.
And this was just one example.
I have a number of regions
of the genome like this,
that are affected both genetically and
epigenetically.
So, this is a case where I have
a change in this particular gene.
It's called a phosphodiesterase gene.
And the point out of all
this is that this gene,
turns out my father's copy is
actually inactivated genetically.
We all have these kinds of mutations,
and then in my case,
my father's gene has actually been
inactivated through a genetic change.
And my mother's copy is actually shut off
by epigenetics, so the control sequences
are modified by this DNA methylation I
mentioned earlier, until we get very few,
very little activity from this gene,
which we can measure by certain readouts,
it's called RNAC printing,
we get very few RNAs that come from this.
So, the point out of all this is that
this gene is then activated in two ways,
one epigenetically, and one genetically.
And as a consequence, I actually have
this again, inaccurate about two methods.
And it fact, I make more eosinophils,
which are involved in
your immune response.
I make more of these
than I normally should.
So, we think that getting your genome
sequence is not only important, but
we also would argue that getting your
epigenome determined as well is going to
be just as important, possibly even
more so, because that's something
you might be able to modify through the
food you eat and your exercise and such.
Well, as I mentioned before,
we've actually scaled this now
to study 100 different people.
We're following 100 people in
incredible detail, just like me.
We sample them every three
months when they're healthy, and
if something unfortunate happens,
like a viral infection or stress response,
we'll sample them more frequently.
We'll take about five or so
extra time points to see what
happens when people get sick.
We've also been running people through
some of these dietary protobations,
these dietary changes to see
the affect of diet on people's health.
And so again, we've been doing this
in incredible detail to see exactly
what happens when people take supplements
or certain other kinds of dietary changes.
And so, we've actually been doing this for
now over three years,
we've collected this,
where we're at the beginning of summer,
we've collected over 1500
time points from people.
So, we're really learning
in incredible detail how
people are when they're healthy, and
what happens when they do get sick.
And just to give you a few examples of
some of the things we learned from this,
it turns out we learned important
health information from almost
every single person we've studied.
So, just to give you some examples
from the genome sequence for
the first 100 people, we've looked at
50 in detail, and three of them have
mutations in their DNA that are very very
important for them to know about, so.
One individual had a mutation in this
gene which puts her at high frequency,
or high risk for
this type of cancer called paraganglioma.
And because she had her genome sequenced,
a simple urine test to keep an eye out for
that, which she would not have
done had we not sequenced her DNA.
She would have no idea that
she was at risk for this.
Another individual has
a protein C mutation,
which puts him at high risk for
coagulation.
And a third person actually has a mutation
that affects their heart rhythm,
and possibility of heart attacks or
heart failures,
something called dilated cardiomyopathy.
So they have a high risk for this, which
got discovered partly through their family
history, and
partly because we sequenced their DNA.
And in fact, they do have some hard issues
that they're taking medications for.
So, just from their DNA alone from
three people turned out to be very,
very useful information about things
they should do to keep an eye out for
possible disease risk.
And so, again, they will use this
information to better manage your health.
It turns out we're also trying to
understand what happens to people when
they gain and when they lose weight, so.
I think many of you, in fact, some of you
may be even experiencing this when people
gain too much weight, and then [INAUDIBLE]
what does that mean biochemically?
Well, we have looked at those,
another group of folks,
many of them I forgot to mention,
but they are actually prediabetic,
and there's a certain type of
prediabetes called insulin resistances,
it puts people at high risk for
type 2 diabetes.
Most of these folks will
get type two diabetes.
So we've been following them in detail
through the same kind of
profiling that I have mentioned.
And as they say, this group of 24
people went through a weight gain,
weight loss study, and half of them
are high-risk for type 2 diabetes,
the other half are normal healthy folks.
And they're matched for their height and
weight, called body mass index,
they're matched for that.
And so, basically,
we wanted to see what happens to these
folks when they gain or lose weight.
And what we discovered,
first of all, even at baseline,
even before they gain or lose weight,
we can tell the prediabetics
apart from the diabetics based
on their molecular composition.
So, this is by looking at
all their RNA molecules.
It turns out the insulin resistant
folks are more elevated for
certain kinds of biochemical pathways,
like oxidative phosphorylation.
They actually have more of a certain
platelets, specific genes that
are stressed and some other diabetes
related genes that are often
prediabetic relative to the insulin
sensitive, these are the healthy folks.
And the same is true for metabolites.
I showed you the RNA, but
here's the metabolites.
So, it turns out the insulin
resistant folks,
the prediabetics are more likely
to have certain metabolites
elevated relative to the sensitive
folks that have other ones.
It correlates very sharply with their
likelihood to get type 2 diabetes,
and so, what's interesting about
this metabolite is it actually
comes from your microbiome of all things.
So, the point out of all this is that your
microcomposition of people who are at risk
for type 2 diabetes and
those who aren't are very, very different.
What we found though is that as
people gain and lose weight,
their biochemistry does
change dramatically.
So, these are the molecules
that do change.
Every row is a different molecule, and
every column, this is at the beginning,
this is after they gain weight,
this is after they lose weight.
So up here,
the molecules will start out low, and
then they get high when people gain
weight, and they go back to low.
And there are other molecules that are
high when they're healthy, and when they
gain weight they actually, these molecules
go down and then they return to normal.
And then there are other interesting
ones that makes their high go low but
actually stay low.
They don't quite come back and
we can actually
identify these patterns systematically and
see the pathways to change.
And the bottom line out of all this is
that when you're gaining weight actually,
one interesting finding was that
your inflammation response goes up.
So your immune response gets
activated when you gain weight and
then it returns to normal
after you lose weight.
Another interesting pathway that changes,
it turns out, is when your
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy pathway.
That's a lot of mumbo-jumbo, but what that
means is that this pathway gets activated,
which puts you at a very high risk for
heart attack when you gain weight.
So we have a biochemical
understanding now,
how people might get heart
attacks when they gain weight.
It comes from the fact that those pathways
activated when you gained weight.
We've also found what turns
out to be really fascinating.
We found that even at baseline,
even when people are healthy at baseline,
their profiles are very, very different.
So these are some very fascinating
immune molecules called cytokines.
It turns out we all have different
levels of these cytokines,
even the baseline when we are healthy.
This is a complicated figure but
each color is a different person.
Each name here around the outside
is the name of the cytokine.
This is high levels and
this is low levels.
What we found for examples, of the blue
person has a lot of this one, IL7.
The light brown person has IP10.
The orange person has this one MIP1B and
so on and so forth.
We all have different levels of cytokine
which probably puts us at risk for
certain diseases differently.
So some of us,
if I were to throw a virus on a room and
half the people might get sick and half
might not, then that might be because we
have different levels of cytokine
that help us fend off those diseases.
As it also turns out, you've heard
about your microbiome perhaps.
Your microbiome is very, very important.
It's the collection of microbes in and
on you and a lot of them are in your gut.
And it's thought that we have
ten times as many bacteria
in our gut as we do human
cells in our whole body.
And so the microbiome is essential for
digesting your food and making essential
vitamins and things like this.
It's a very, very important good thing.
It's not always bad like
you might be worried about.
But it turns out,
if we look at people's microbiome,
everybody's microbiome is different.
That's been known for some time that
we all have different microbiome but
some people can be different
in interesting ways.
This is two people here who eat a lot
of almonds and they're very different.
This is a way of relating people
to one another in this plot.
If you're similar,
you'll be very close to each other.
Well these two individuals
eat a lot of almonds.
It's a family, the husband and
wife, they eat a lot of almonds and
they were just very different
from everyone else.
So your diet can really shape your
microbiome and long term changes.
What we found is that for
short term perturbations,
like the weight gain study I mentioned or
viral infections, you will shift your
microbiome but you actually look closest
to your self rather than someone else.
So this is just comparing people
in different time points.
Every color is a different person and
it turns out the people are like this red
person, if we ask who's closest to who,
well even if you gain weight or
have a viral infection,
your microbiome will look closest to
yourself, rather than someone else.
So the point out of all this is that we
all have personal microbiomes that shift
when we do gain weight, or
when we get a viral infection, and
it's a short term perturbation.
It will shift but you'll still look
closest to you, your bacteria and
things are very personalized.
And that's probably because we tend to
eat very similar diets and our genome and
epigenome help control all of this.
So this is really where I
think all this is going.
I see a world where we'll be
able to understand where people,
when they're faced with different
perturbation, so some people if they eat
unhealthy they will gain weight and
become metabolically a mess.
Other people, if they eat unhealthy, they
actually may gain weight or they may not.
But, even if they gain weight,
they can stay metabolically healthy.
There are plenty of vary obese people
who don't have Type 2 Diabetes and
we'd like to understand biochemically why
that is so we can better manage people.
Certainly we can try and
make sure that they eat healthy foods but
we should make sure that they
eat healthy foods for them.
And the food can be very specific for
individuals.
We're also trying to
understand how certain people,
when they get viral infections, some
get sick but some others stay healthy.
And, again, we'd like to try and
keep people as healthy as possible
from these circumstances.
This isn't the only study we're running.
We're running another one,
where once a year we're profiling
people from around the world.
Actually it is part of a meeting
that I am involved in,
it is called
the Human Proteome Organization.
We actually are, part of this we
actually go around and sample people and
follow their biochemical composition.
We do this once a year
at the annual meeting.
And, so we'll be running around the world
picking out crops of people to see
how biochemically different
they are from one another.
There's other projects out there as well,
I've just listed a few here.
So, there's one in Seattle run by
Lee Hood, another in Sweden, and so
on and so forth.
There's a number of projects now
erupting like this around the world.
Where people are trying to understand
biochemical detail, what it means
to be healthy and
what happens when people get sick.
There's also a new exciting area that's
going to play into this in a big way and
this is using wearables and sensors to be
able to better manage people's health.
So I mentioned all the biochemical
measurements but there's now getting to be
devices that let you measure many, many
different physiological sorts of things.
In fact, believe it or not,
there's over 500 health related devices
on the market that let you measure
all kinds of different things.
And I don't have time to
summarize them all but
I'll tell you about a few of these.
The simple ones are things like scales
that you can stand on that will
actually measure your weight.
And they will send that
information into your smart phone.
There are continuous glucose monitors
which is especially useful for
type one and type two diabetics.
These devices actually prick onto you and
they will continuously
measure your glucose.
Probably the most popular device that
you're aware of, the smart watches,
there's well over 50
available on the market.
They measure all kinds
of interesting things.
They measure your activity,
how many steps, running, biking.
They'll measure skin temperature.
They can measure,
it depends on the device, but
they can measure your sleep,
stress responses, and so on.
They measure all kinds of things.
And they're measuring, again,
in a continuous fashion.
And what's important is that these
devices collect information and
they relay that back into your smart
phone and what that means is in
the future your smart phone is going
to be your nexus of health information.
All this information is going
to relay back into you,
into your smart phone, and collect this.
And to be honest, I use eight of these
devices everyday to collect information.
It totals up to about two million data
points per day that you can collect and
even if you don't have time for
all of those devices,
you can actually download
free apps on your iPhone.
And get some of these as well,
this is one I use.
It's a free app that lets you
measure your steps, your biking,
your running and also tells you
where you are all at the same time.
So again this information will
all collect into your iPhone and
help manage it, so why is this important?
Well if you think about it,
you probably go to a doctor at most,
once a year if you're healthy.
And they probably see you for about 15
minutes, maybe 30 minutes if you're lucky.
And so out of the 370,000
waking minutes in a year.
The doctor just sees you for just
the tiniest possible fraction of them,
a tiny drop in a very, very large bucket.
So we think there's value to actually
being able to measure people all the time,
collect a lot of data,
and a lot of information about a person
over a long period and not just in that 15
minutes where you wonder if that's
representative of your health state.
But by collecting this all the time, you
really get a pretty good idea of what your
baseline heart rate is and
if it's changing and this sort of thing.
I can tell you personally, what this is
going to mean is that, in the future,
your smartphone, it's really
going to be your command center,
your control center for
collecting all this information.
And you [INAUDIBLE] biochemical
information in here too and
that will be able to help you
better manage your health.
To give you a personal experience out of
this, when I got Lyme disease last summer
in 2015, my wearables were actually
incredibly valuable for discovering this.
In fact because I discovered that my
oxygen level is lower than it was
supposed to be.
My heart rate was elevated and
I knew things weren't quite right.
And then I got a low grade fever for
four days and
in the end I was able to figure
out it was Lyme disease.
I was in Norway so it's a big deal,
they don't have much Lyme disease there.
In fact the person recommended
I got penicillin and
I told them I think I need doxicyclin.
And if I hadn't had the wearables,
first of all the wearables helped
me find this in the first place.
And then by taking command of my situation
I was actually able to get the right drug.
So, I think that's going to be one
of many examples in the future where
these wearables will feed directly
to you and then you'll use them and
go to the doctor to help
better manage your health.
And so, we'll not only have
biochemical measurements,
we'll have all these physiological
measurements as well.
So, this is Mike Snyder's future.
I envision a world where people will be
getting their genome sequenced before
they're born.
In addition to all these
biochemical measures,
we're going to have wearable information
as well that all feeds back.
Again ideally it would feed back to
real time release and short time.
And with this, we'll be able to
better predict disease risk,
catch disease early, monitor disease and
treat it all based on all this
information, the so-called big data.
And the nice part about it is I hope in
the future, we'll be shifting medicine
from being a reactive situation,
where we react when people get sick.
To proactive where we work
to keep people healthy.
That's really the goal.
And so again, here's where we're at,
personal genome sequencing is here.
All these other multi-omics
profiling's really important.
I think the longitudinal
profiles are very, very valuable.
Everyone is unique, so everyone's special,
not just to the mother.
They have different biochemical profiles.
And I think we are all going to be
responsible for our own health.
So that's wrapping it up,
I'm going to turn back over to Annette and
yeah happy to take questions
if people have any.
We have a wonderful lab and
wonderful collaborators.
These are the people who
helped out in the study.
So, back to you Annette.
>> Great, thanks Mike.
So, before we do some quick questions,
I'd like to tell you a little bit
about our program and our center.
So, the Stanford Center for Professional
Development makes it possible for today's
best and brightest professionals to
enroll in Stanford University courses and
programs while they
maintain their careers.
Curriculum from Stanford departments
is delivered online at Stanford,
at company work sites, and
international locations,
providing a global community of learners
with flexibility and convenience and
enabling them to apply their
education to their work.
Additionally the Stanford Center for
Professional Development has a long
history of extending the world class
teaching and research of Stanford faculty
to industry corporations of all sizes.
From start ups to mature
of successful enterprises.
Visit scpd.stanford.edu to learn more.
So now we have a few questions, so Mike,
when will this become
available to everyone?
>> Well right now it's a research
project so the way we carry it out,
it really is just for
a limited number of people,
a hundred folks we're following
in incredible detail.
But I think some form of this
will come out in the future.
Obviously, the wearables are there now.
I think we're going to see, they're
starting to be some companies forming in
this area about measuring a lot more data,
to be able to manage people's health.
So I'm guessing, so
some levels rolling out now, it's not
covered In a typical doctor's appointment.
But it wouldn't surprise me
if from five to ten years,
we'll see a lot of this activity.
Certainly, by ten years,
I think we'll see a lot.
It won't be quite as deep as what we're
doing on me and these 100 people.
But I think it will still
have a lot of data to
be able to better manage people's health.
And I didn't mention but imaging data,
some of these other things are going to
be very, very important as well.
>> Great, so with that thought, is that
such a thing as too much information?
>> Well from my standpoint my answer is
no, some people maybe overwhelmed by this.
But I think you can manage the kind of
information that you want to come to you.
So yes it's billions of data points but
in the end it always distills into a few
common themes like either you're sick or
you're healthy or
you have a viral infection.
Maybe you have Lyme disease.
So it won't be like you'll get
flooded with billions of data points.
You'll get filled with possible things
that you should be on the alert for.
And some people know they
won't want this information.
You don't want to wake up
every morning and worry.
I'm going to get Lyme disease,
or I'm going to get cancer.
That would not be a very
healthy situation.
So if you're a worrier and you're worried
about this stuff, my recommendation would
be that you just limit the information
that comes back to you.
Only, it would pop up if it seems a very
strong likelihood that this'll happen,
or there are certain simple
tests you should be doing.
So I think that threshold of what
information you want to come back
to you will differ for different people.
And again worriers should probably
get less information, people who can
handle lots of information, by all means
let them have whatever they can handle.
>> Yeah great so with all the information,
and all the different devices,
and all these different collection
of data What about the privacy?
Who owns all of this information?
>> Yeah, well at the end of the day
I think you're the owner of your own
information in my opinion.
Now you do have to be coached
about this in a sense that we do
have genetic counselors involved
who let people know that they
may learn things they don't
want to hear about and such.
So we do want to manage that.
But as far as privacy in terms of
insurance companies and things,
at least in the US, you're not allowed
to be discriminated for employment or
health information.
Although, you can for long term
disability and for life insurance.
So those two, you can be discriminated
against so that is a possible concern.
I would still argue it's better
to know the information and
stay healthy and possibly pay a little
more for life insurance if you have to.
That would be better than the alternative
which is to be unhealthy and not know.
So it is a trade off.
Unfortunately, it'd be nice, obviously,
if there wasn't any discrimination on
those things, but it's somewhat limited.
I haven't heard any strong cases of
insurance companies discriminating or
people discriminating against others
based on their genetic information.
Although, it is conceivable it
could happen in the future.
But yeah, I think again, number one
priority would be to stay healthy.
And I think the information
can help you do that.
I think for privacy, we should try and
manage it as best we can.
These days, I don't think you could
ever say anything is completely secure.
So even if you thought you were [LAUGH]
storing it in a very, very safe place,
there's a distinct chance that it will get
hacked and somebody may have access to it.
And that's why we'd like to avoid
any discrimination based on
this sort of information.
>> Yeah, thanks.
This is very informative and
I think everyone can really take
from this talk so thank you.
So again, if you like this topic and
you're interested in more information,
this webinar is presented by the Stanford
Genetics and Genomics Certificate Program.
Visit geneticscertificate.stanford.edu for
more information.
Thank you everyone for listening.
>> Bye all.